die hasen geben die wohl war zu früh
aber in gold
und schon würde du hast du ausgerufen
und das pferd läuft auf mich zu alter
ich hatte so angst
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge minecraft hero
zusammen mit veh wie hey hallo
bei mir hat es gar des todes angefangen
zu regnen also das ist richtig heftig
gerade bei mir und bei mir kommt die
folge ein bisschen später als bei rewe
und ich lege ich bin gestorben
aber ich bin im tor ist screen und es
ist mitten in der nacht und ich bin bei
den teleporter ich hoffe mal dass ich
jetzt nicht sterbe auf dem weg ich hab
ja ich verliere direkten herzalter ich
bin ein alter ich bin alt marie ich bin
direkt gespannt und ich bin direkt mit
komplett keinem leben gespannt
ich hatte keinen hunger mehr keine
balken
was kann das denn seit ich geboren und
ist porno ohne dings ich spanne einfach
oder so gut
ich spanne ohnehin arbeiten da kann ich
doch nichts für ich sterbe ich sterbe
ohne wirklich sterben schnell was zu
essen kann ich nicht ist es mit in der
nacht ohne witz was ist das was ist denn
das weil das sollen dass also das nicht
fährt also das ist nicht fair dass das
gefäß bot das ganze mag ich hab's alles
aufwand ich habe es oft band dass ich
reingekommen bin im tode spielen weil
ich konnte er letztmalig respawn war
kein grabstein geholt hat aller regel
ich bin rein ich habe kein leben ich
hatte keine chance zu überleben
dann würde ich das schon tot dann würde
ich einfach das kannst du dich irgendwie
retten das nichts zu erinnern
ich bin ich was kann ich denn dafür wird
es bauen einfach wieder neue da wird
keiner nach krems nämlich jetzt ich hab
jetzt auch nur ich habe jetzt auch nur
300 alten man müsste eigentlich voll
haben wenn man neues point normalerweise
schon ja was soll denn das alter die
wollen mich doch alle verarschen und es
ist mitten in der nacht die
dementsprechend sehe ich keine zeit
keine schweine oder so hinter mir das
geld junge was kann ich denn dafür dass
ist doch junge wie scheiße ist das thema
lukas unit hilfe
da dies das denn das ist richtig
behindert ich sehe auch nur schafe
gerade passiert sowas nicht das darf
nicht passieren eigentlich ich habe
jetzt mal wie ich jetzt mal gestorben
wegen wegen hunger halt damit ich die
ganze zeit im todes spielen gewesen weil
kein grabstein holen konnte eine
autonomie alter ja und dann müsste doch
eigentlich wenn ich wie es vorne dürfte
ich eigentlich volle leben haben
in der theorie her schon ja wenn ich nun
auch in der praxis koppelten sich
schützen
ich sehe nur schafe kannst du eventuell
schlafen gehen weil dann kann ich
ausschlafen eventuell spawnen partien
also ich hab eine was so manchen also
ich respawn jetzt einfach nur wenn jetzt
irgend jemand schreibt so auch luca
mensch du das ist doch so unfair
was kann ich dafür jetzt genau gesehen
das werde ich auch wie man zeigen und
ich weiß nicht welche sonst kontrolle
hat ich glaube für simon
ja das weiß schon wer aber mal ehrlich
dass es unfair und da sollte man dann
schon luca institution gewähren
münchen stier so ich habe zwei
rucksäcken und sophies alte löwe geht
dieses schwert ach so sehe ich noch mehr
tätig
ich brauche jetzt holz wo kriegt denn
jetzt holz her glaubt an bord haben
diamanten klar aber ich frag mich
beschwert jetzt habe ich eins und hat
große diamant schwert lukas warum sagst
du dir lukas was ist mit mir ich habe
auch ein großes diamant schwert ist das
krass das ist ja das wasser doppelt so
stark wie normales der mann schwer mainz
liegt halt ganz normalen irgendeiner
anderen kiste die ich letzten mal
gerettet hat kurz bevor ich gestorben
bin ich brauche erstmal holz und ich
will nicht in den wald laufen weil er
sie mir viel zu viele mops aber da
hinten sehe ich irgendwas holz ist ja
hier auch gut revier jetzt tue mir bitte
den gefallen und geschlafen
natürlich bin ich draußen holy shit
alter kehrt ist das scheiße alter ist
das scheiße
die krokodile die machen nichts die
machen nichts was die slawischen passt
und als spinner eltern ein dass im
pinguine
die das mich angreifen ich behindert
junge okay ich gebe peña will ich
brauche noch mal richtig dass eine
holzheizung allerdings machen musste den
mann der welt aber heftig beim hex
it-entwickler beschweren dass mein kopf
es fehlt einfach mal kopf locker ich geh
kaputt
ja und jetzt dieser hinweis da die folge
war luca später kommt wenn ihr die
abenteuer des jungen konkret aussehen
möglich
auf dem kanal vorbei schauen ja und nein
ich mich alle verteidigt
alex war luca nicht passieren da muss
man schon fair sein
dieser fuhr gestellt wie 'n roll
gestellt für die zeit
wir sind gerade bei fünf minuten 10 ich
sehe das so ich muss mich jetzt erstmal
darum kümmern das jetzt irgendwie noch
mehr zu fressen bekommen habe ich ein
bisschen ins farmen begeben ich bin also
sicher dass krokodile nichts machen
brauner bär aber ich weiß nicht ob er in
passivem ob sind das weiß ich nicht
während sind passiv recht aber ich habe
mal ein geboxt weil ich dachte ich wäre
besser als der bisschen trotz black wer
kein brauchbarer syndrom im aggressiv
auch schon die ganze zeit angekündigt
eine goldkette oder willi marihuana
verpackt mit dem ausmaß von uns treffen
wollten
wegen horst da oben sind zombies mit
rüstung altern die verbrennt nicht weil
die rüstung haben junge wie op ist das
denn bitte unter schießt auf mich und da
ist ein kripo schluss will ich gerade
abenteuer
ich streife gerade durch die welt
keys und aber jetzt bitte den schnee wie
soll da ist größer sagte musa dagh
endlich genug analyse alter das geilste
zeug in ganz practice einfach diese
junge ohne dass dieses leuchtende links
nein du unwissender erkennen können user
oh mein gott sagt schnell was diese user
es ist der stoff der elemente froh macht
mein gott luca frage was blüht alles sah
ich hab diese wir haben gesagt sag mir
was alles los
wir haben eine krise bruderschaft ok ok
dieser bruderschaft geht es darum diese
knolle mit dem namen bücher zu verehren
okay jetzt wir beide oder da sind jungs
und ich wissen die wiesen die ritter der
giesel krone
ja ok ständig und darf damit rein in die
sekte ja du musst halt du musst mit dem
anführer schlafen und das ist im alter
bestimmt nein ich noch größeres minus
als so manche was sagt der fuchs das
wissen manche leute jetzt aber was ist
dieser vorrat für boxfans gut findest du
scheiße oder wie jetzt viel zu gut ich
wusste vorher nicht also im fuchs macht
in hexe macht ja so tweet geräusche wie
so eine vision obdachlose mann zufällig
wie soll man zufällig darauf tritt ich
wahnsinnig was für obdachlose in köln
hat europa ich sag's dir richtig
gefährlich man
bestes lied ohne witz wie kann es also
die leute die es nicht kennen
dort behindert sagt ihr seid geistig
behinderte pv so viel action max11 da
war ich bin ein bisschen farbe namen
kommt damit klar ich will jedes einzelne
ich kann hier keine blöcke abbauen wegen
ich kann ihnen jemand glaube ich auch
nicht abbringen sport action liga weiß
was sie gewusst
wilde allerbeste sein keiner vor mir war
der junge schon während schwarzer bär
pass mal auf jungs zum schwarzen bären
kummer ich laufe ganz normale meinem
eine hungerkur hier drunter hunger keule
voyager colin kolles
ich laufe über eine eisfläche hier war
ich ja schon mal
ja ich versuche nur dass ich irgendwie
zurück zu diesem ort komme wo ich meine
kiste stehen gelassen habe das sind
pilze ich mache mir pilzsuppe junge
bauer pilzsuppe genau warum bin ich
nicht früher auf die idee gekommen waren
wieder so ein schwarzer bär als an jeder
ecke lauern schwarze beeren digger das
wollen die kommen wir müssen die
schwarzenberger nahrung geben
bist du der bronx wir müssen schwarzen
bären jetzt namen geben alte das
bisschen mal via probieren probieren
nein mit deren namen von richtigen namen
etwas gutes lil wayne is cool anspruch
wieder von verona wird sonst immer
schüsseln
man müsse da wollen mich verarschen ist
immer schlimm ist was anderes im tod
stuhl ist gar kein mushroom was ist ein
tod stuhl tod stuhl das ist dass es das
des todes kaka tod stuhl
ich weiß nicht was es ist und menschen
die gestorben sind die aa total.com wie
man mit weg jetzt leid aber ich nehme
aufgeweckt nein es ist kein witz gepäck
also nein ich nehme auf greg brown
ich brauche dich papa ratzi der hose
wieder alter ich raffe es nicht re wie
ich habe hunger keulen
nein kein wlan kabel kommen jetzt halt
dein maul ohne wirklich geht
du bist immer hin und her ohne wind
keine braune roten ich bin kein rot bild
einfach aber einfach gerade hier drin
und wissen wie das w lan kabel auf das
wiederkommen wollen sie haben das wieder
ein passwort scheiße das dann so eines
porno tun
ok zweieinhalb hunger keulen alter
schreibt meine kommentare ob ich das
schaffe noch bis zu einem punkt da hatte
ich da überhaupt was zu essen mit ich
weiß es gar nicht nur kommentare denkt
ihr dass ich es noch schaffe oder denke
eher so an lokaler spender schafft das
ähnlich einen daumen hoch wenn du gerne
ananas schnauze bitte junge das ist ein
wettkampf ein wettlauf mit dem ding
machen hinsicht ein wettlauf gegen die
zeit
ein wettlauf gegen die zeit
ich weiß doch hier war mein erster punkt
für behinderte junggeburth ich würd ich
will hier war mein 1 ab und gut
zweieinhalb hunger keulen scheiße digger
schüsse bis ich habe zweieinhalb ist
kann nicht sein
ich finde nichts zu essen guckt euch
bitte einfach die folge an ich finde
einfach nichts zu essen was soll ich
denn sonst machen ich könnte meinen
namen jetzt sie irgendwohin tun und
einfach warten bis er wächst als weizen
seien aber junge hier ist einfach
nirgendwo schwein oder sowas hier ist
einfach nichts ich habe so lenders ich
habe etwas gefunden
hier spornen einfach gar keine schweine
schweig still do knecht ich hab das
gefunden
das gefährt ist dass meine idee ist vom
feld gestorben macht das lieber nicht ob
das wohl fertig vielleicht dass drogba
sanyo th sind geben die wohl zu früh
ich hoffe du hast du hast beruf und das
pferd läuft auf mich zu alter ich hatte
so angst ich hab ein paar grad ich hoffe
dass das jetzt hier in roth tritt das
sonnenrot bin ich doch dessen rotes ja
es ist eine rot-weiß essen ja mama mama
minecraft wenn man ist warmes essen
es ist schön dich zu kennen mit dir zu
lieben und mit ihr zu schmusen
ok ich erstmal um sind irgendwo noch
mehrmals passen pferd das kohle eisen
bäume krokodil auf dem berg jeder weg
jeder weg und wilsberg krokodile herbe
heftig gefährlichen hexengruppen ende
links ich würde die kukksi wann sie den
israelis
ich hab einen zombie gehirn gefunden
seither ist das kann ich das mal essen
das schicke euch das lava das und rot
blitze zwei rot pilze alle rollen sind
erwarte ich ein wenig gesehen aber ich
hab dich gesehen pinguin besser
töte den pinguin alter pinguin später in
green tötete pinguin ich habe den kopf
bekommen
schreib deine kommentare hashtag tötet
den pinguinen bei chemie des todes
behindert pinguine sind die bösesten
tiere im ganzen haben mich bei dem bei
der bei dem trailer alle stand schönen
rhein ich will einfach von einem pinguin
von tadel getötet der den einfach
gespannt womit der kürze und hans-peter
esch haben so schön so klar dass ein
endermann juni wenn der ändern netz vor
der nase den pilz cloud ich höre ich
boxen richard eine frage mit ja
was sagt er ändern na ja so ganz klein
ist einfach so ein klo ist immer schwer
wie lange geht es noch alter ich habe
eine minute
gems gefunden ich hab im skeleton kopf
gefunden den letzten jetzt auf der die
einfach so rum laufen zu schreiben ich
nein manuel bis zum erliegen überall
juli liegen überall sechslinge rum von
großen bäumen alte schädlinge schädlinge
wobei ich ihn herum schützlinge aber das
komische sonne jungen auf einmal den
schnee die um vorfall berlin pinguin
doch pinguin komplette hintere echt nur
braun pilz was es denn mit rotwild muss
rot leute denken ich bin komplett
geistig behindert
ich geh jetzt noch eben zurück in mein
mann und ich geschlafen gute nacht ja
danach können wir absolut geht schlafen
natürlich alter denn dann hole ich jetzt
auch im bettchen raus dann können wir
zusammen schlafen geht mitte links im
bett ja ich auf schlaf gut lupe und wie
sehen die nächsten folge von ich muss
meinen euro projekt nein ich habe schon
im kopf drin alter warum passiert das
immer bei fraps sein kann da nicht
falsche taste ich muss wirklich noch
eben ganz kurz zurück zu meinem gebäude
damit auch nicht lange das dauert nur
ich sehe sogar schon auf der karte idee
auf der karte wenn er auf die karte
kopiert wenn das die fans kindes ist da
unten rechts auf der karosse da ist ein
hase den box jetzt auch noch eben
einfach aus prinzip einfach die karte
war lukaku
seit der hase mit geben der hase hat dir
ein lose gibt einem fleisch luca warum
sagt man mir das denn nicht er es reicht
jetzt reicht's jetzt das war's von dj
ich bin direkt also ohne betreff
internet doch a20 blöcke levi will ich
meinen um ein gott alter was ist das
denn
auf malta bei mir ist einfach so ein
riesiger baum müssen sich ja junge
erwarte ein eine sekunde an eine sekunde
der preis würde dann hörst du schon mal
auf ich mache noch ganz ganz kurz weiter
ich bin hier noch eben drin ich mache
jetzt noch eben eine suppe die ich dann
jetzt schon mal verspeisen werde und
dann ich muss mich echt mal ein bisschen
vorsorgen jetzt mit suppen also ich hab
jetzt ich hab fast voll leben das ist
richtig geil ich hab dir gesehen haben
der anderen dass er selbst okay leute
egal wenn es euch gefällt ihr dass du
mir gar kein fahne mit redit und auch
pinguine hass und die auch vox er liebt
und das total gegessen als in ägypten
daumen hoch und wir sind dann einfach in
der nächsten folge vom server und ich
bin auf jeden fall froh dass ich jetzt
das ist nahrungsquelle gefunden habe
hieß kanal das an deinen beschreibung